he makes us money when we need ya a
billion Oh last a dream ness Evan
Carmichael I'm going around teaching
believe I am doing this while I'm
driving so let's look for no accidents
to you happy birthday happy birthday
heaven so it's the belief cake I didn't
want to celebrate on my own so I'm doing
it with my friends hi Evan I wanted to
wish you a happy birthday you are such a
great guy and you know when you talk
about believe I actually really believe
it you're one of these special lights in
the world really offering kindness care
compassion you just seem to understand
what it is that people need and you go
the extra distance I'm so impressed with
you Evan and I hope that you make this a
fabulous year hey Evan I just wanted to
say have a fantastic birthday I just
want to thank you you've been there for
me and my business for the last nine
years anytime I needed help you're more
than welcome are more than happy to give
it to me and I really appreciate that
and you're a really good friend so
thanks babe whoo happy birthday cheers
bye happy birthday from Liberia